how's Gomes my welcome to jazzpunk I
just really wanted to gut did I really
just kickin stupid we're now in the
united partitions of breath silly isn't
it supposed to be like this it is myself
I am okay I'm doing this that's cool all
right
in my country okay yeah okay and then we
take a little detour up into oh [ __ ] the
bad sector new frosty York okay let's go
to Sweden hell yeah what if it's it what
wait country formerly known as friends
what nether regions germanium Stockholm
sit that's that's a so offensive
so wait you were that are I'll have
Finland doesn't even get anything
Denmark is it not even on the map haha
silly Danish people why am I doing this
Free Tibet with every purchase what
telecom I know China quad Korea Russia
Siberia of course Thailand party yeah
if this were we supposed to go okay
there we go
cacti whatever going on hi I forgot what
we were doing [ __ ] gay man all right
all right I talked I Hotel Resort the
beach is that way I don't know if I want
to go did we crash the submarine gotta
go get this Cup
hey go yeah your waka uh [ __ ] man yeah I
can't keep up with this game this is
like too much [ __ ] going on it what is
that a sheep instead of what is yes
reload no goddamn it no what oh nice can
I ride him I want to ride him
what are you go where you going all
right come back here I'll get him later
what do you want hey man can you spare a
minute to shave my back hmm
okay check oh god what's that well
that's actually kind of convenient hey
guy you're welcome also that is not your
back both side of nebula I share this
chest he tracked me that's it
oh hello girl what is that man totally
go check out the beach should I ran it
at all like everything say his is
awesome sounds like cry when he's drunk
they're not my parents we should totally
go check out my dad oh yeah
what is happening I had a business idea
furniture got shut up you know I don't
really have like a mom and dad what
happened to the girl what does she flew
off early and anything however and
then I get our way muah-muah [ __ ] pig
man I can't go here no they they freak
me out man
all rights go to the beach yeah it'd be
generating eighty this is like the new
Playstation 4 graphics holy [ __ ]
oh no I wanted a frame hey one little Oh
nice bounce hey guys I'm so glad they
chlorinated the ocean all the sea
creatures were crows yeah it's true sea
creatures are [ __ ] girls man
especially see me that shit's [ __ ]
girls man
nitrous adding those sun waves man
alright we have a wedding cake here for
some [ __ ] reason and it it has a
keyboard yes of course my eyes but did I
just get married plague a Mexican okay
cats fight this is quake
champagne oh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] I need a better weapon I'm gonna
die oh god what the [ __ ]
hardly whoa [ __ ] here oh no not to say I
stopped yes
goddamn this guy's tough man oh God who
the [ __ ] again
no it's at an edge
how do they know my ping I want to play
again [ __ ] cheeks man I need a better
weapon this time whoa oh yeah baby
you [ __ ] egg is mine now what oh my
god
oh [ __ ] hmm ultra marriage [ __ ] it's
gotta go for the best weapon in the game
man was that the sound of a [ __ ] goat
yeah holy blank fifty-nine lives happily
ever after
wedding quake okay that was [ __ ]
awesome
this is why I love this game man this
game is too good man I say man way too
much man all right you can collect these
for some reason I'm not sure ghosts in
the taco shell ghost in the shell' I got
it funny it's [ __ ] funny man oh no
it's the turtle Oh God had I dunno tie
up Rafael was actually my favorite
Channel Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle kid admit a
little here come on kid I want my pizza
back at least you're not where I want it
better yeah that's why I worry better
that's right I imagine you come often to
perform you're pushing me are they doing
said moon Lutheran April toilet as
actually chance of course tomorrow
it's not what the [ __ ] you're talking
about
all right let's try to hit on some
ladies hey guys president and I got MMA
my god oh my god oh my god ha ha oh my
gosh shut if you say oh my god oh my god
I'm gonna oh my god are your face
my daddy's president oh god shut up and
god damn yeah damn yo how's it going
what all those guys sound like they have
to take a [ __ ] really bad oh I obviously
missed something here okay what I've got
mmm I look for trashes
I got damaged wine I have used this
earlier we're supposed to find six
objects oh my [ __ ] god I got a player
rated uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
break it down out of him go oh right
right bug bite bite bite bite bite bite
bite bite bite bite bite bite
okay 106 okay oh my god a Paris sonic
game Keith I didn't know they had a game
console you got spam you got spam 30-day
free trial and we gotta that's great hi
there we go oh my god most valuable in
the gamer really me me oh no you're just
saying that no stop it
I know I'm the [ __ ] [ __ ] man a nice
Kim ha ha ha ok thought it was a little
tinier but ok I'm ok with that
ah
is okay
public domain carbonite what do we got
here what did I do
okay sorry to keep you waiting that's
okay ah I'm afraid conscience not a
literal currency well I was told
specifically there was opportunity
signed into law just burger how did it
did make all right four or five four huh
Plus that's catechu I guess by buffler
okay 405 baby I need this for my
exercise that is look I'm taller I
became a horse okay
of course why why would I
I was one as big horse
did he just count you and so that's what
really happened why is there water
coming from there I'm not a horse
anymore come on I wanted to be a horse
make me a horse again it's not a
pewdiepie I think that's a hipster pie
and he's just bear smoke okay 4:05 was
it four or five here we go baby
oh nice room Oh already but I just
entered where's my phone must be this
lemon right I stay banana but it's one
awesome phone how comes
oh god damn it you have me the same
phone as me oh really mr. Atlanta saw it
possibly an opportunity to pass up
violet duplicate attache case that's
very distracting then swap the cases
maybe I better get close enough
hold on Dylan balls are feeling a little
classy look for the mountain glasses
island peligro watch your back
whatever okay god damn I thought we were
gonna have fun and [ __ ] that's awesome
lemon man oh [ __ ] how can I be on it
yeah
ah well see ya guys check that what is
this what am I supposed to - put the
[ __ ] oscillating Oh were you get
justice
oh I'm pretty down mmm oh yeah let's do
it well uh just make sure it's all
covered I think I look pretty probably
look very very fabulous very beautiful a
little bit over here - and then one
little dirt there there we go
ah god damn it oh man alright my like I
kissed the door to open because wine
okay we're going to the bar I first hope
you enjoyed this episode if you did go
ahead and leave a like I really
appreciate it I love playing this game
so I'm happy you bros fun more that's
that's awesome so to keep showing your
support I really do appreciate it it's a
Rufus for you lovely boys
you